welcome to this video this is about the
seventh match game of the towns and
honored match currently played in Sochi
yeah Game seven yeah in Game six
thousand squad the win to take the lead
in the match this really remarkable game
with this double blunder ben Carson gave
away the game basically on a silver
plate but Holland didn't recognize his
chance and then subsequently lost the
game yeah after that we now continue the
match with another white game by cars
yeah in after six games at the middle of
the match so to say they switch them and
then they switch the colors in a way and
there are two subsequent white games by
cars and so game six white and games
heaven white again the reason is that
after every two games there is a there's
a rest day and they want to make sure
that after the rest days both players
have white and black the same amount of
time this is actually quite illogical
thing that was never really thought of
in previous matches they do this for a
number of years now but it was never
thought that say in the 80s earlier okay
let's see what happened we have again
efore it seems that Carlton is staying
with this move for this match and on and
playing a five okay so we've got a
surprise again we get a rillo pass and
island is playing the villain again so
the same opening that he had put his
trust in in game let me think about it
this was game game too right what's this
game to it was game to rather the game
that he lost um and Cal's now placed
differently he played d3 earlier in this
mentioned game two that he wanted but
now he plays castle so actually allowing
the boolean endgame yeah and term
yeah well this is certainly one of the
most topical lines and grand master
chess in the last let's say 15 years but
it really is nothing that excites
spectators very much and to be honest
also not the commentator yeah here we
get the notorious Berlin Wall end game
that rises here after black takes takes
the Queen on d 8 yeah this end game it
is a big problem for one year for
players nowadays and its really tough to
get to get anywhere um I will say that I
never look at this from the white side
what I did is years ago when I started
to play 105 on 1.e4 i started with
actually playing the berlin as a
somewhat time saving option is black and
only later switched to to a 6 and other
lines in the in the rue is black and i
always thought that this end game is a
very serious option for black players
even on a on a non grand master level
because um it's still somewhat
interesting position something that you
can play however on the super GM level
they have analyzed is so deep now that
you can hardly play it and just get a
game let's continue a little bit white
played age 3 this is a normally use for
moving those structures it prepares g4
at the right moment and also have some
other positive effects for example
provides a square for the bishop things
like that 93 and h5 one of the numerous
setups that like is playing this is also
problem for white black has so many
different setups that you can play
Bishop f4 you should be seven root d1
there should be six or very normal and
one big point of this age five movies
that it makes very difficult for y to
ever play G for what wyd wants to do
long-term he wants to use his pawn
majority has got four against three on
the Kings side but it's very difficult
to get this majority in motion as the
light squared Bishop is such a good
locator and this light square blockade
is emphasized with H 595 now is played
by carlson and island replies Luke age
60 this has been played a number of
times the idea of this rook move is of
course that if white now decides to
capture we can actually retake with the
rook and make sure that our pawn
structure has not changed the pawn
structure with okay here here the
capture is making and no sense
whatsoever as rook hangs but in general
if we look at the structure the
substructure that black normally wants
to avoid getting this pawn from f 76 so
it's a good idea to play rook aged 6 to
make sure you can capture with the rook
yeah cards now played the move g3 yeah
this is the preparation move from what
happens later it also makes sure that if
black plays h4 we have g4 easily
available Bishop takes g5 a very drastic
decision by Anna but very often this
trade is something that black welcomes
trading the dark squared bishop against
the night the reason is that now we have
opposite colored bishops and this means
that like on not the opposite colored
bishops but it means that black has two
locating pieces on light squares while
white has a dark square piece which is
not really helpful in the advance of the
King side however we are already talking
about very concrete things here after h4
this rock is strapped yeah why does
simply doing this if black is is not
reacting so black needs to go f6 and did
it sell
takes takes Bishop f4 or this is forced
and now Knight takes h4 so black has one
upon Iran h4 and yeah at first when I
when I saw this in the in the broadcast
it was a little bit irritated because
they played it so fast yeah of course
the reason for the quick play was then
it is all holy known position and has
been played before even more than once
yeah cards now played the move f3
slightly mysterious looking moves but i
think the the next couple of moves make
make the idea clear what white wants to
do and this is really a good idea and
wants to play king f2 and then look aged
one to pick up to pick up the h5 pawn
and this is this is happening in short
order why does the pawn down but you
will get it back on each five however
after up the aid in order to get this to
get this on the board he here had to
give up day to pawn Oh quite funny and
this really was still played almost
instantly they reach this position with
both sides having spent about 15 to 20
minutes so it was mostly yeah playing
the moves out writing them down and
briefly checking okay are we still on
the right track so it seems that both
players and you the position in fact the
move g-form was played only a couple of
days ago in the tournament in Tashkent
between geary and raja baath we can go
forward up to here in this position here
on move 25 years so we're really deep
into the game
here um where is it in my notes here a
job of of all people even even he is
playing the Berliners black isn't this
terrible he really played lots of
interesting lines against the roy the
Schliemann gambit and so on and now we
see him play the Berlin endgame um yeah
he played f5 in this game against
against geary and after g5 they had a
somewhat different type of endgame why
does a pawn down but he has some serious
compensation in terms of Owen with them
active sorry with the more active pieces
and this dangerous Jeep on it seems
however that aren't any different idea
in mind he played night f7 and I'm
totally sure that he knew about the game
here I mean this is pretty clear night
f7 is what Allen played and now night
III and this is really a rare case I
mean no I really don't want to be a yeah
disrespectful or anything but this is a
rare case of a good cause and opening
preparation what he's now coming up with
is really a great plan here Carl and his
team they had envisioned an interesting
idea and the idea is that the night will
be transferred on the way to h5 and this
is a really nice idea the night on age 5
or let's say on g3 first we really put
enormous pressure on black we see this
happening now night comes to 5c 5 yeah
black couldn't take yeah that's
important yeah because this is a double
attack so this night is is really a
problem peace for for black yeah c5
force plate not the capture and now cars
went back to g3 yeah and here we come to
the situation that I described white now
has a nice pressure for a sacrifice pawn
there are many ideas that are really
annoying the the toughest one in a way
is when the
comes to age five there's also simply
the idea of moving the bishop somewhere
I'm not sure where and then I have four
back form fork on those two pieces the
position is really not not easy for
black to play and it turned out that um
alle not took took quite some time to
work out what did what he does Ness next
and I think what he did now with 95 he
was already envisioning what happens
later in the game 95 and cousin played
this check yeah instead of ninety-five
of course black could have done other
things ya like like b6 kindy seven but
as mentioned the night will come here
and it's really not so not so clear what
what black should do many many
problematic ideas IAM even sometimes the
capture can be an idea in the 9f for
black really has a hard time to defend
this also note that he is totally tied
down to defending his weakness OC
especially f6 um yeah i think that that
Allen smooth was actually okay but it
really involves a very radical
transposition and well we we see this we
see this later okay let's jump back to
the game 95 or so move yeah Cardinal
gave this check rook g8 this should be
five little tactic of course black can
now take here because this will pick up
the rug in the corner so f takes Andrew
cage five very interesting position now
and I think this is what island had seen
when he decided to play 95 in this
position that the normal looking move is
looking evade I guess yeah Black has to
do something concrete if he's not doing
anything concrete then white will just
take this pawn and then have two
connected pesos this is really nothing
that black
once too wants to play so rookie of
eight is the most normal-looking move
the thing is that after King III again
rupee five is threatened so Bishop d5
must come and then we pretty much by
force get to this end game and this is
quite interesting if you look at it with
the computer it will only give white a
slight advantage but probably this is a
position where black is in grave danger
of losing it's simply a case where the
computer is not calculating deep enough
if you it's a matter of calculation time
of course but those pawns I mean this is
something that a human can judge pretty
intuitively those pawns are more
dangerous than those pawns simply
because those prawns because they are
more advanced and the white rook is
doing a good job and keeping things a
little bit back well the white pawns can
march unhindered this is a very very
critical position from like and very
hard to avoid once you go for Rookie of
aid in this position and unplayed
differently he played a very radical
move instead of rook evade he took on g4
just sacrificing a piece very this is a
very brave move really yeah what happens
after that oky takes it of course and
will be five yeah b6 black has to keep
the pawn yeah so this was what
unattended mind he is going to a
position where he is a piece down for
two points but everything is on the same
side of the board we've got four points
against two and black has the king near
spawn so the king is a useful defender
of the pawns a very important point is
of course that white cannot win with
rook and night against rook so simply
trading stuff down and try to simply
yeah liquidate all pawns mode win the
game what white needs to do and we might
as well go ahead a couple of moves
because this is kind of clear what why
did
brought the King over somewhere around
here we can we can start start to look
for plans yeah the thing is that it is
some pretty clear that Wyatt does not
have many plans in this position the
only very apparent thing that there is
is a combined attack against c7 but how
exactly is it going to accomplish that
yeah you can put a hook on the 7th rank
and then try to maneuver night near the
pawn that that's not difficult that's
not easy to do night cannot easily come
to d5 or come to e6 so on a very
difficult position to win and maybe an
impossible position to win let's have a
look for what happened in the game yeah
why does try to activate rook on g7 and
now the next shrine is to get a night
somewhere to d5 the thing is that even
if you get it to d5 it's not very often
helping you as you don't have any
support something like that is a leading
nowhere there's those little-little
ideas help to save black it is difficult
really to evaluate this this end game
with complete certainty I think with
enough time um probably there will be a
definite answer the general meaning
meaning the general opinion of most
watching grandmasters was that they
found the draw more likely than a win
but they wasn't they weren't really sure
so let's see what happened in the game
King c3 now think
all this is I mean can be looked at in
more detail but a lot of it is just a
little bit of marking time and just
poking around here we come to something
committal c4 think probably that white
cannot do without the move in the long
run the main reason is that you want a
post on d5 for your night so that the
knight on d5 in connection with the rook
can actually oops can set up this attack
formation on c7 however it is not clear
that it brings much as we see aland is
ready to play b5 and probably this is
the this is the right decision he is now
ready to advance his pawns and try to
trade pawns ultimately of course black
wants to trade all the pawns but with b5
this is a really committal decision
because it we can see 5 a lot so it
could happen that this pawn will become
a fatal weakness but it seems that he
has judged as well in the game we see
that Carlton gets his night to reform
but ultimately he couldn't get anywhere
near c5 a second time can only take it
once but the rook on the 5th ring this
is why the rook h5 move was good this
rook is just protecting this and black
has a counter play of course with this
King rookie for ya and somewhere around
here we come to a key moment aland give
a couple of checks and here it is very
important that he judged the next move
correctly he now captured on c4 a very
ugly-looking move but on concrete terms
it is the right decision let us just
look at the the two possible answers if
white takes with the beep horn
Black has relatively easy came it just
goes here text the pond so there is this
idea and also of course and more
importantly the a poor now has a very
easy easy task it just starts to run and
will be difficult for white stop he has
to really yeah give up the c4 bomb
probably to stop the point in time so
taking with the point is really nonsense
rook takes e4 was played in the game
yeah and now we see islands idea he
played rook to g3 attacking the poll on
b3 night x looks good yeah but King b5
Roxy two and A five yeah and the thing
is that he has calculated correctly that
King before were net enough counter play
with this idea of playing rook c3 a very
good and precise calculation the thing
is that white can never move this night
as b3 then is falling directly and there
is absolutely no way to improve upon
what happens now calzon played this look
to the side look see one marking time
king before kini to roots III this was
impossible to prevent and it means that
now Wyatt doesn't have any choice he of
course cannot trade the rook if he would
do that he has no way to prevent this
and the pawn capture so after Luke's III
there really is only what happened in
the game 93 check King takes the pawn
check on a rougarou k1 and we get to
this end game now black has managed to
trade all white spawns and this means
he's basically safe now the best that
white can now achieve his rook and night
against rook which is a draw in fact in
the game they continued this for quite a
long while
do this quite quickly yeah black black
already has no a chance to avoid losing
the pawns but it's not a big deal i mean
you rather want to jettison the pawns
quickly to get to the 50 moves away of
course also the sea porn was falling
yeah and we had a couple of more moves
even we're now on move 110 and it
continued a while shuffle shuffle
shuffle and here garden called it a day
with Roxy one allowing the rook trade
yeah he's here ethically speaking could
have played about 30 moves more but rook
um and night against rook really is a
total draw there are cases where the DH
an extra night side one but this is
mostly in situations where there was no
increment and there was the defending
side really had no time on the clock and
at some point ran into a fork or some
silly business which is not happening
here as they play with a serious time
control um yeah what to make of this
game we we had a long theoretical
discussion about 25 moves we're already
known up to this point if we jump back
here and this seems to be a position
where black is really suffering a bit so
in this case really in a successful
preparation by carls and steam I think
that it was a very brave and I think
correct decision by Anand to go to this
to this end game I mean maybe some
analyst will find out that there is a
win for white but I mean I doubt it but
maybe there is one but in practical
terms I think this was a much better
chance to defend then to to go for this
race situation endgame here this this
kind of thing that I showed here it's
maybe possible that black is just lost
and in the game we could always fight on
so a draw in this game
no change in the match I think Anna can
be satisfied with this it wasn't fun to
defend all that but to do so
successfully it's also something that
can give you a little bit of a boost
yeah I hope you enjoyed it it wasn't the
most exciting of games but still it's
it's part of the match and I think also
an important important point of it now
that Carlton has had two whites are not
this back again with the white game
tomorrow so this is certainly a
situation where he wants to try to win
okay thanks for watching